le professeur que pensez-vous de
l'épidémie de grippe italienne en veux
tu en voilà résolument contre c'était
les années 40 et les actualités
françaises s'amuse et de l'épidémie de
grippe qui s'abattait sur la france
[Musique]
l'humoriste pierre dac donner ses
conseils en 1949 des vitamines a et la
carotte justement à l'eau contient
il ya donc eu lieu alors la vad
un des pilotes
[Applaudissements]
et puis sinon il y avait le bon vieux
grog remède implacable contre le méchant
virus 1,71 c'était toujours mieux que
d'aller chez le médecin le docteur
nouveaux malades après oui et faute de
gnôle la famille partait à la cueillette
ben non par an il allait chercher des
preuves dans les champs du chiendent
oui alors il avait bien sa pulpeuse et
birsa et médée les pruneaux des raisins
un peu de filles et puis fait des beaux
murs avec du suspens digne et vous
donnez savoir c'était bon créée morts
certains étaient persuadés d'être
immunisé accueil par les vaccins la
grippe ne pouvait pas les évents les
salles une famille nous avons et 15 de
faire autrement dit que nous sommes
vulnérables
mais surtout il y avait ce côté
fatalistes face à l'épidémie de grippe
puisqu'on y peut rien alors autant en
rire déjà à l'époque préhistorique
la grippe se traitait par inhalation
voici un modèle de petit inhalateur
naturel et volcanique et cette dame
interviewé la caméra bien calé sur son
nez qui coule la prescription c'est
simple on va lui donner un petit peu
d'aspirine commettre ou le monde comme à
tout le monde c'est encore ce qui marche
le mieux dans ce cas là un petit peu dit
amine c'est pour tenir le coup il va
boire beaucoup et dans la peinture dit
très fier même pas encore accomplir à
twitter elle doit terminer normalement
voilà vous savez ce qu'ils affirment et
puis si ça persiste et retour au grog
il en pose c'est quoi justement le
professeur dac huit années grubb par 24
heures dans la proportion de 10 gouttes
d'eau pour un livre de rome
[Musique]